you know what you signed up for
no friends
no relationships
what we do is too important when
governments fail the only thing left is
the charter
the most highly trained agent it's a
bigger operation
no political leanings
no National agencies
working together to keep peace in a
turbulent world
how many in the welcome party six of
them
she's developing a sense of humor
is what gives the chart
so they can crush a market or drop a
plane out for Skye
if you want the heart
you own the world
we've been reached
what's happening our systems are offline
we've lost the heart and now you
answered me
you're compromised
don't know if you can be trusted
I'm standing you down Rachel I don't
care you have no idea what they're
capable of I need to shut it all down
show time
is
you think you know everything but the
world is about to say the truth
of success just plummeted
only because you've got no imagination
[Music]
thank you